hey guys and welcome to nerding out the
show where we gamespot nerds get
together and talk about the shows that
we like and today we're talking about
the walking dead season 7 episode 3 the
cell let's do this alright guys i am
with aaron spencer and buddy let's talk
walking dead so Dwight is a human being
right yeah he's actually we've learned a
little bit about his backstory yeah he's
actually human he's actually human which
is great because it gives more shed more
light to his character and we actually
had to finally see his wife again who's
no longer his wife it's his ex-wife now
it's negan zwei and that also pays into
the idea of why do I still there he's
from what we've seen especially during
the moment of their sharing a cigarette
is that they're both still technically
in a white kid together but they're more
like checking in upon each other now and
I think Dwight's they're mostly because
he wants look after his wife and his
wife they're primarily now to maybe even
help Darrell because she feels guilty
for what happened to him she tried to
stop him from leaving and so I'm hoping
that maybe Dwight and his ex-wife wound
up getting Darrell out of there we'll
have to wait and see well wait and see
well speaking of Darrell's so we got to
see what's going on with Darrell I was
worried the entire last week I was like
uh where's Darryl what's happening to
him yeah way to go and now we finally
see the kind of torture that he's going
through so Aaron let's talk about Darryl
oh my god tortured the torture was so
good because there's a story arc through
the whole episode in beginning Dwight
just cannot enjoy that beautiful
sandwich that he's made he just he wants
to eat it dog foods and you just cannot
do it and then he proceeds to torture
Darryl the whole episode but the reveal
at the end of the episode is that
Darrell is actually torturing Dwight and
that's why he can't enjoy his damn
sandwich it's because Darryl knows you
can't take negan can't really do much
against negan but he can screw with
Dwight and Dwight doesn't even want to
be there his job is to break Darryl and
he just can't do it and Darryl's just
not giving in to him and he's not doing
it because he's torturing Dwight haha
the tables have turned so negan torture
techniques so poor darrell has to deal
with not only Alpo sandwiches but also
just extremely loud blaring pop
is it the worst song ever me naked is a
tortured genius and what's weird as you
realize that the torture never stops
like he's always thinking about how he
can intimidate someone like the example
is that that that Polaroid of of squishy
head Glenn they took that you saw them
take that and then he you know Dwight
tapes it to the wall probably on
Meegan's insistence but the music the
song that was being used easy oh god
it's it's completely opposite of
everything that's happening yeah perfect
yeah so just position you even see that
great moment where he pulls Dwight aside
and gives him a little bit of like
leadership management training do they
have like a little workshop before he
like you know he gets out of it on his
own he makes a dumb excuse but and he's
even going after de white as well when
he even mentions in that he's doing such
a great job would you like some a blast
from the past when he's mentioning his
ex-wife and you could just see it in his
face he's like I'm good let's talk about
the zombie field now so what is the true
purpose of this anyone anyone didn't
know it could be a number of things i
think it's it's more self like a trick
it could be a training field like better
your zombie skills you know zombie 101 I
think it's more torture I think it's I
think yeah you'd send people that are
being trained to be future Nagin's
through their over and over you or that
could also be people who betrayed negan
didn't follow the rules and even in
death they still serve a purpose for him
yes as a reminder for them I think
that's what it is i think negan is
reminding everybody who's under him that
you don't get the easy way out you don't
get to just die you're gonna work for me
one way or the other and you're either
gonna work for me like I'm gonna screw
with you and so you just work me
willingly I'll find leverage like I'll
marry your wife cuz you owe me or hey if
you're useless to me and you're not even
as good as like a water boy or something
i'll just put you out in the zombie feel
then you're my guard dog lined up on the
fence you don't get to die then you're
my pet that's it oh and that's powerful
too cuz even in death you still serve
him wow he is quite the villain yeah so
next week we have service any
predictions Spencer uh I mean I think
that we're going to see a little bit too
next week is the fact that Rick screw i
think is going to be a little divided
here i know a lot of them are going to
want to fight negan whether as Rick I
think is going to try at home guys maybe
we don't sit we don't stand a chance
against him either now or ever so I
think there's gonna be some there's
gonna be some riffs happening between
the group it's edited to kind of show
that they're fighting Meegan's group and
then Rick I'm no longer the leader it's
negan yeah what do you think Rick's crew
are the new heavy hitters for negan I
mean they killed his old crew he'd put
all that time and energy into recruiting
them speaking like they don't they don't
make good sandwiches like they're not
good at farming I guess I can build some
walls I mean they're the guys who kill
people right that's what they do and
that negan knows that so I think he's
gonna have him killing other settlements
or recruiting other settlements for him
cuz he's super lazy he doesn't want to
do that so himself he is he burns a lot
of calories swing and Lucille and as
techniques are so great that that's why
he doesn't have to work very hard
because there's torture techniques just
get the job done for it so it kind of
works itself I do want to know if the
ammo factor is going to come back into
play though yeah so in a previous
episode we learned that Rick's crew is
capable of making a mo they might be one
of the only people who can do that and
everybody is running out of bullets we
learn that from hilltop so that's I'm
wondering of them an edge yeah like is
that a card they're gonna hold to
themselves or they just gonna play that
one right away it could be used for them
like for the kingdom and for hilltop and
for them to build up an arsenal because
Nikki's already got an arsenal so they
need one of their own now especially
Nietzscheans come to claim his share of
supplies so all right well great
predictions will see if any of them come
true next week for the episode service
thanks for checking out nerding out and
we'll see you next time